[Music]
I come back to Carnegie Mellon every
year if I can because I had a very good
experience here as an undergrad it was
enormous ly valuable to me in my pursuit
of my career I have a continuing desire
to give something back to the school
because I felt it gave me a lot in many
ways this is our ninth year out of this
cabaret the singer-songwriters cabaret
and we've introduced some amazing
composers to our students and we're
really so happy to welcome back Stephen
Schwartz having him come in and revealed
these things that I'm sure he spent
nights and nights late nights working on
tearing his heart open or stitching it
together with these songs it's a
blessing to be able to to collaborate
with him and have him coach us his songs
have so much heart and soul there's no
greater composer in my estimation that
has the greater humanity than Stephen
Schwartz Carnegie Mellon promotes
individualism people kind of being
themselves and the point of a cabaret is
you don't play a character you play
yourself just singing a song and singing
words that aren't yours wicked was a
very important musical for me when I was
child and I remember when it first came
out and I remember having the album and
listening to it a lot I'm getting to
sing a duet with my best friend Kate
from wicked
it is kind of surreal and like to grow
up listening to this music and all of a
sudden now I'm in this world I feel
really honored and grateful it also kind
of reminds me that I'm not too far off
from all of that anymore which is really
thrilling and nerve-wracking and
exciting I'm quite certain I would not
have had the career that I've been
fortunate enough to have without the
training I experienced a carnegie but
also the growing up I was able to do I
came out of the school a much more
complete person than I was going in I'm
not sure all undergraduate experiences
deliver it but Carnegie Mellon certainly
delivered that for me